even yeah so you look at the question it
provides you all this information about
the parabola what it passes what certain
conditions you know the chord must meet
and so on okay so we'll do that P stands
for okay so we're gonna form equations
for x and y that rely on whatever
parameters we've got okay C stands for
yep so we'll combine them two equations
into one so then we get rid of all the
parameters just rely on X and last step
of course is okay so and yesterday by
the way for this for this particular
Marcus right all we did was the first
method out of the two for working out
the restriction so we just did a
graphical method the geometric method
and we skipped the algebraic method I'll
come back to it today we'll look at the
descriptor because I'm actually going to
give you a special example to release
that but I'm getting home result anyway
now we're on to the second question once
the loss of the intersection of the
tangents but come from the two points
were interested in okay so if we're
dealing with data first okay what kind
of data do I already know remember this
whole situation is about this parabola x
squared equals 8y okay so I still have
the same you know a equals two that I
did from before that hasn't changed
right
what else did I know about this
good yes so these tangents right it's
not just any tendons its tangents
through these two points in particular
and these two points I'm not just any
random points that are actually related
to each other
namely through this was a 2-0 or is it
zero to zero so what we did was we got
the equation of the chord didn't we and
we had to get that from scratch right
and then we sucked at this point and we
got this guy remember that yeah and then
that was the end of our first step we've
gotten on a dime okay now being that
it's still the same chord right this
still applies this is still going to be
true okay so we'll use that briefly now
I can get on to the parametric equations
now okay so I've got to have an x equals
and a y equals right and the point of
interest interested in all the points
are the intersection of tangents okay so
if I'm gonna work out where the tensions
intersect what am I going to need to
know before that yeah that's right and
I'm just like with the equation of the
chord early art which led us to this
okay we have to work out what those
equations are we can't just point them
unless the question just says you may
ask you and that you are if you've seen
some of the past papers it actually says
you may assume that an odd do not prove
and so on okay and you see that the
number of marks on the question is lower
to reflect that right so equations are
the tangents is two of them how do we go
about finding the equations of the
tangents do the first one
I know I know the point that it passes
through right and I will also know it's
radiant because it's a tangent okay so
I'm gonna use quite reasonable okay now
what can we establish what were the
coordinates because a equals 2
right some point on the parabola P was
what was it 4 P 2 P squared all right so
there are X&Y coordinates so we'll pop
them in Y minus 2 P squared no gradient
at that point is P that's why we that's
why we chose the parameter right so P at
the front X minus okay you know I mean
that's not an equation in some ways I
mean that goes right back to the
definition of Y we said it's for P to be
squared it's because that's the problem
that's the gradient map would never mock
devoted to States the definition of pain
why it's relevant and so on okay so I
think you find it right okay let's just
signify out a little bit that's going to
be P X that's minus 4p squared and
there's a two piece when it's come from
the other side
so let's view here's what off the pages
okay sir
similarly the tangent ooh
how's this secretly okay great so now
that I've got the tangents I can
actually find the community section so
let's do that we'll solve simultaneously
so point of intersection let each
equation okay so what do i watch here
I've only got X's in their lives right
so I'm about to find the parametric
equation for x let's just make X's
subject yeah put that over so far so
good
I can factorize and then divide through
I think you can see though that I just
have to divide by P minus Q right which
will leave me with this difference of
squares so this will be 2 P plus 2 Q all
right great so one parametric equation
done how do I find the other one I'll
stop back in what should I so back into
yeah either of these doesn't matter
right because both of the intersect at
that point solution should satisfy query
so y equals I'll just take the first one
P times X yep - P squared there - P
squared there so they cancel that leaves
me - PQ ok now here's one of the
advantages you're like why do I bother
memorizing all this results that are in
the program for like intersection of ear
so chords blah blah it's not so you can
quit though it's so that way you get to
this point you can recognize okay that
the coordinates of the intersection the
tangents are a outside of P plus Q
that's the x coordinate and the y
coordinate is a PQ we already knew what
it was right
so at this point it's just sort of a
helpful check for yourself you like yeah
I'm on the right track all good so far
okay great so dad I've done primary
pressures done Cartesian equation how do
I put it together now in previous
questions because what you end up with
that final Bacchus you get is a parabola
right but where do you combine them will
involve squaring in some way okay
because this has to have a degree of two
but when you look at how this an X
equation and this Y equation relate to
each other there are no squares right
this is linear and P and Q and this is
also linear in P and Q so I don't need
to square anything so what should I do
I could do that but I feel like it's a
it's doing extra work we don't need to
especially given that reason why we did
this step is precisely to allow us to
put these things together right so 2 PQ
is equal to P plus Q right I can put
that into this line like there's 2 times
sorry 19 times already it's just P plus
Q right and you probably should say you
know from equation whatever we name it I
got right yeah does that make sense the
reason why I can use it is because that
comes from the same set up same question
okay so now how do I relate that to the
X well that's double all of sorry half
all of this okay so that's 1/2 right I'm
finished that's it
that's Locust that's the Cartesian
equator okay
so I've done this I'm not this now I've
got to work out a restriction okay so
like we said before you can use the
geometric proof or you can use the
discriminant because we've already got
the graph here I just gonna call this
hit y equals x pumped where's this gonna
go through
that's terrible
there's my feeble attempt at x1 - I know
it actually goes to that point because
that's for - so what was on what is this
point that we're trying to find again
this locker sir points is the
intersection of the tangents right and
wherever your tangents go where they
intersect must be outside okay so what
time am i interested in no I didn't
thank you for minding me
but regardless instead of inside which
is what I had before the first part
because the midpoint on the outside okay
which interestingly without doing any
work is exactly the same restriction as
the first question the restriction is
it's less than or equal to zero or not
inclusive for me what we went down and
greater than you could fall okay now
I'll let you have a thing as to why it's
so convenient that the restriction works
out to be identical though for the
opposite reason okay but that's the
question so maybe the a crucial step was
realizing you could use this from the
first question a lot of people forgot
that they're like oh I thought this was
related just to the midpoint thing right
it's not because it's the same chord
that presupposes all this okay so it's
the same condition